oh look what I found
we do have our old pip saved in the
backup studio oh do you want to use that
instead yep
hi everyone welcome back to resident can
evil it's Saturday October 27th take a
break from a Red Dead Redemption - to
watch some us play Resident Evil is so
nice of you that's such a nice thing for
you to do Mike cuz I know you guys are
in the middle of some serious red dead
spot very serious red dead stuff right
now
if you haven't noticed yet we're in our
backup stream room I don't know that's
kind of mean to this room I like this
room a lot in our second room the
background is like colorful yeah if you
hear weird noises there's like a video
shoot happening right outside this room
as well we're in the belly of it if
that's even a phrase so last time we got
a lot done we were doing some elevator
action with Claire Claire Rebecca and
Billy using the dumbwaiter and [ __ ] yeah
I don't know a lot about what's going on
but I know that I have a cable-car fuse
I think you also have both my peeps are
fine I had a really good episode last
night last time yeah well let's not brag
yeah I think it was you got that fuse I
got this fuse as well as I thought you
got like a something else let me see
probably I'm doing so great but oh my
god he's reading room key I forgot about
the key it's got a whoa so I think our
objective right now is to meet back up
because you're still on separate floors
hideous monster the visits
as cool as me it's a cool-looking Keith
alright so sorry so I have a key let's
actually like talk about this a decent
amount of bullies but not a lot
shotgun she's got a decent mounted Bulls
a fault I got [ __ ] heels for days I
feel so good yeah so here's the thing
though they're not together oh your note
isn't in the through oh yeah what's a
good thing shotgun shells are in the
morn Billy's floor in the morgue whoa we
need t-shirts I'm gonna boss we do have
merchandise for gamespot but we don't
have it for the show that matters so I'm
kidding there are a lot of great shows I
didn't mean that nobody else is watching
nobody watches I love potato mode I love
potatoes yes get my boy good Knievel
does not have shirts and we need them
kind of this rogue splinter cell that
branched off from gamespot yeah it's on
Billy's floor the shotgun shells okay so
he's full so what I'm gonna do is I'm
gonna send something down I can't on
birth the breeding room door always
filled with monkeys no no the breeding
room key is the wrong key scenario no
what was your fixation with monkeys you
keep interrupting knew it wasn't the
monkeys I think Rebecca needs the
breeding room key regardless because
it's on the first floor
Molly sent the bullets oops
who's on who's who's on the first floor
she is I think he's on the second floor
because he's upstairs so he's gonna I'm
gonna give mm excuse me I'm gonna give
he's all chatting matches so we're sure
I'm pretty sure he is
second floor B b1 from basement one and
basement too so she she is on the but
the lower floor yeah
so yes the breeding room door is one of
these up here oh so he needs it yeah
okay well that's good to know
so let me ask you this
my based on my inventory which is a key
a full he'll three bullets and a shotgun
and about to get more shells you need
the shotgun in the shells soon but you
also the breeding room key so yeah just
get the shotgun shells then come back
and do the breeding room no shotgun
shells rebec this way I think oh I
thought they were in the morgue
yeah the morgue is back this way I think
it was past the bust of Marcus no
monkeys no monkeys the monkeys monkeys
are you sure I thought they were we can
do it there that but we are handy-dandy
yeah oh I did [ __ ] out what about these
mall tops
I don't know honestly I mean where were
they they're like two rooms over but
it's not like a big deal if that's you
know I'm gonna save my life like I'll
totally do it
oh the glare in this room is not great
I'm gonna go on our discord see if
there's been any activity oh yeah the
one that uh who was Nathan Shepherd said
I did a bad job I'm in it because I care
about our viewers I'm dumb oh [ __ ]
there's a whole separate channel now in
it called future Knievel suggestions Wow
it's specific oh man it's been a checked
in a few weeks ago when I first joined
so yeah so I'm Anning that's great that
people want to talk
I'd like it to live on I believe pretty
fully like even after as an evil it will
be nice to like do something else just
cuz it's fun to do yeah
Nathan Shepard is always one of our best
one of our most dedicated viewers has
been updating this I I should that's
okay I'm gonna read through here if
you're not in this let me find the ID
again or Nathan Shepard it is sorry so
should I get these Molotov couldn't hurt
to have him I don't think you'll have
room though I would have to get rid of
my gun but my god don't worry about the
Molotov so I know yeah you don't need
the Molotov my gun only has three
bullets you need a shotgun anyway okay
um where am I going
I don't know it's one of those it's it's
one of the Reds yeah it's the breeding
room key will unlock it alright we'll
just go I'll just figure it out I should
probably change to the shotgun and
monkeys monkeys monkeys cool I'll just
switch to it no just said I feel safer
and I will pull up my mappy okay so it
could be here but it could also be that
other red door so let's check this out
first
it was sorry Heather H was saying was
this two weeks ago when we didn't have
an episode she said so missing out on my
head of Kennedy this week I went back to
the latest episode the last episode from
re one and if somehow ended up on
episode three of retinol too
one of my highlights has been Mike
employee imploring Mary to use healthy
use healthy yourself yeah I thought I
told you not to yourself you don't tell
me enough and now Mary's the one
convincing Mike that healing at yellow
is the right thing to do I feel strongly
based on maybe just like my levels of
anxiety that I would rather have I would
rather feel I would rather be safe than
sorry when it comes to health it's a
fair approach well cuz code Veronica I
was more worried about ammo but as
people pointed out I was too worried by
ammo is this the breeding room there's
like cages that have been opened almost
like there was something bread in here
bear traces of being smashed open from
the inside this cage is rusted there's a
patch of dried blood oh Lord
this is not good hunters
those are hunters
oh you [ __ ]
Jesus that delayed there's another one
little bit did I hit him I thought I did
suck it out Billy stop frequently I
think you're still fine Billy can take
it could've been jeez that's unfortunate
because I thought I'd I thought I was
doing pretty good but I you know you
can't even take one hit from those jerks
oh yeah yeah yeah there's a note no I
want to read the note
research to date has shown that when the
originator virus violence cellular
changes whoops
via coordination of the cellular level
for the growth experiments here's what I
learned in secta so okay so they're just
high-energy and aggressive and fib Ian's
the frog-leaping power and tong growth
no change
those are hunters I think it sounds
right they're like Teenage Mutant Ninja
Turtles but scary actually they always
scared me to Mammalia um monkey oh my
god
are they actually monkeys unsatisfied
with weapons does seems that no progress
can be made without making humans the
base okay he's very interesting this
cage is about the same height as a human
kid Oh remember this cage says human on
it like a safe dial cuz there was a
clock downstairs that Rebecca needed or
no I think Rebecca needs that dial okay
I can I can handle that
woof this room sucks all right well I
got a dial so I can send that in the
dumbwaiter to her no monkeys nobody's
noise
okay so I need to go straight that takes
me to the dumbwaiter it's something easy
to get turned around in here I feel like
I took a week off even though I didn't
that's just how I feel we're recording
this on it Tuesday
kind of early for a week this early cuz
uh twitchcon is this weekend so I leave
oh I can talk about Red Dead now when
it's published um I got spoil anything
I'm like four I'm like 50 well
technically if you tell me you're
breaking the embargo to me but I would
never tell anyone because I would never
hurt you oh yeah actually I shouldn't
actually I think some of my rock stars a
Knievel fan so I'm not going to hahaha
but if the embargo releases by fret
Saturday Thursday night oh then you're
fine right I mean I don't want I'm just
saying I would know right but I would
never hurt you like well I mean I can
say I'm at this point at the point where
recording I'm like 40 hours in Wow
oh wait Rob showed me some gameplay that
was so funny there's so many characters
in this game that are like obviously
they put a lot of work into the dialogue
to make sure that they don't just say
like howdy like they have full
backstories they react to you they react
to you they have like a whole thing
going on there their outfits are
indicative of who they are and all of
their stats right like their fighting
ability they're you know just their
their look like oh god there was some
really funny stuff that I was seeing
earlier and I just feel like it's a it's
obvious to put a lot of pull out TLC in
that thing yeah based on that kotake
reports came out today maybe a little
too much yeah it's kind of been a poorly
kept secret about Rockstar for a while
now well I mean it's not just Rockstar
right like a lot of places do that I
feel like rockstars getting the brunt of
it CD Projekt RED said it's a necessary
evil to crunch which sucks cuz they also
made a really good big game a few years
ago and they're working on one right now
it's hard to
defend and I think I'm allowed to say
this cuz I don't feel like hey Owen get
that mad at me but I feel like crunch is
like inevitable and almost any job where
you put your heart into your work so
similarly in GameSpot I used to work
into like 9:00 p.m. all the time it
wasn't because like if I didn't I was
gonna get fired that wasn't the thing it
was just that I cared about what I was
making and I didn't want it to suck that
I stayed late and developers feel that
too they want the thing that they spend
so much time on to be good so they
[ __ ] stay because they want it to be
an awesome product and they want
whatever they worked on to be valuable
and wonderful and that's really hard to
deny that's not I mean yes there's
problems with culture in that sense but
I don't regret working late on any of my
videos because they were better because
of it and I love my videos so yeah like
this is probably like a not so popular
opinion but I know people are saying
that the per the parts yeah if your
passion about something it's they love
into their work like look Berkeley the
the more troubling parts the reports are
people lower on the ladder monkeys
monkeys monkeys monkeys who came in on
the weekends just just two so there were
people so it Rockstar wanted people in
on the weekends when Sam and dan Houser
stopped by so like they wouldn't be put
off that people weren't working on the
weekend so it's like it was like a
pressure here yeah but that was
everything it was pressure apparently
its pressure from the top down from the
upper people that you're it's not
mandatory overtime but it's kind of like
it's like working overtime or else
you're just like not gonna move up great
well I mean again like at GameSpy Li
have you had good videos like you're
you're killing it like you'd have to
work late to put put in the videos I'm
not saying like they're different like
things here but it's like you know
you're late [ __ ] I wrote down that thing
oh I have it I should have it somewhere
I wrote down the code for this member
that was on the other stream room as
well me here we go
four eight six three I think eight four
eight six three it was that like math
thing it's like oh we were experimenting
on these samples you wrote it down yeah
for her eight six three right cuz it was
like we had four monkeys and then when
they doubled and then he lost something
but I don't know how you have to turn it
I imagine like a normal lock right oh
would that be right yeah
when I had a locker it was four four but
then you had to go past the second
number I don't think that's gonna matter
here eight and then 600 I did I ruin it
oh I guess it doesn't matter the order
we were very much overthinking this what
a B or D yeah well I mean no not that
when I was in when I was in school oh
that's the same thing now like my gym
locker has that I wouldn't by the
numbers yeah it's been so long since
I've opened up a log like two games
should I be going in here I got a gun I
don't have any mall tops he could send
me some I'm pretty sure you're reuniting
on the other side of that door okay and
if not it'll be funny to watch me oh for
[ __ ] I well that's your headphone where
I was
that's okay I can't I don't have like
sensory sorry that did not sound like
who's Roger she's put her walkie-talkie
back into her dukes is she safe who
knows or cares Oh first so that's what
that fuses for I would imagine totally
but like I'm just saying like can I move
to him then should I walk around I think
you've got to like unlock something as
her first yeah okay so I'll become him
know her and then but he said he was
gonna be right there yeah but that's
still I would still explore the room
first cuz I think she he doesn't know if
something's locked right like we're also
thinking too hard about this game I
think no she can't it's like god yeah oh
yeah lever right there
the glare is pretty bad in here ooh that
was a brash poll
there we go now he can come down oh that
does look familiar he was in there
before yeah that was for her what
happened there but he was in there now
he can come down I don't remember where
he was um open the map right there
bottom of the steer no no sorry up new
this the typewriter
that's the ladder going down is right
there that wasn't there before all right
well I should get some of these items
great or is he full you could probably
save did you do enough to say yeah you
don't think I did I really don't think I
did okay I did like one thing okay
I killed two of those guys right or am i
coming back cuz I'm saying if you're
about to take a cable car somewhere I
have no idea what's gonna have any other
side and you I think you have enough ink
ribbons to to save your soul little I
understand like should I bring should I
bring the like all my guns
you know they trick you [ __ ] it's not
what I meant to do that's okay
like what is this yellow thing okay I
don't know if I need that but I do want
the hookshot you do I do need the
hookshot
yes oh yeah Y ie it's not like you're
not really get it I think you need it to
even progress past this point right now
okay so it's I'm just saving me like too
pathetic yeah no monkeys nobodies
No No there we go
all right so we'll do that and then
we'll get a couple
okay straight and get your Maltese and
your other things it's too far from the
end of the game no well I mean like it's
not gonna it's not like a next episode
thing this is not the penultimate but
well there's a lot in here yeah you were
in here before briefly I forgot what you
got you run in that classroom right
there so you've got like another section
of the game so there's ink ribbons here
should I save right now is that what
you're telling me how many are there
three plus the ones you already have
I think so yeah oh no there's the ones
on the floor are the ones you dropped I
mean yeah there's just one more that's
it always says that I think it's three
oh you're right
well where are the other ones that you
dropped she's got one can you open your
map and see if you have other ones
somewhere sure I still think you have
enough because you're gonna find more
I'm sure I will
so that's how you zoom no no just so you
know remember those old was it Mazda the
zoom zoom zoom
commercials okay so there's somewhere
that ages that there's one here that's
like way back oh no that's know what
that's fine to save
diabla people dressed like clowns right
outside the door
that is so Diablo yeah I don't know what
the the idea of the video is pick this
up you little [ __ ]
I can't take all this stuff with me in
fact I can't take anything with me I
can't even take these Malta's I'll give
them all toast to Rebecca oh yeah I see
I'm sorry you can't even like bring them
down there no like I'm so full well you
have a ladder right there you can come
right back up
oh yeah okay I'll be right back
I was creepy they're dressed like clowns
and I had that I mean they're just doing
their job but they're not that shooting
is way over in the other side of the
building they're just hanging out well
if they're not doing their jobs and they
don't have a lot to stand on
he didn't quiet down at all
tell me okay sorry it's okay um so I
know Rebecca probably wants the Molotov
she says she has room okay anything else
you left ink ribbons and the hookshot up
there he has the hook shot but I could
take the ribbons are you saying I should
take the ribbons no no no
there's also up a plant a green plant
there but we have full heels okay good
there's also a shiny thing over here oh
yeah that's the output or input yeah
okay so now you've got the input and the
output right does that fuse think she
has the yeah
do I combine these I don't think so you
just use them on the same thing okay
okay
is it this I don't know oh is it the
hookshot yeah
is that what I have to do yeah I think
Billy wants
okay so doesn't matter who goes where I
wonder hmm I don't know um [ __ ] this is
gonna be annoying
I say use I say oh I'm not too concerned
well go up there with Billy okay but
give him the input and output coils he's
got to give up everything then no he
needs a hook shot okay so I'm gonna get
rid of his I'm gonna leave these things
then yeah okay and I'm gonna boobs
it's [ __ ] balls all right here we go
all right give me cool
that's your slow hook shot oh good
can you even pick those up yet uh no you
guys put the coils in I guess okay
Oh
was that
that's just normal train noise I don't
know idea trains are pretty foreboding
switch to Rebekah well that didn't
really help she might still not be safe
its train noise I can feel it that's a
door to your laughing
you know now you're back up here you
have to climb down again with him right
that's why this thing was unlocked from
the outside how convenient
get I can't I can't get in there it's a
mental block that was cleverly designed
come on right come here baby
so he can't take all this stuff but does
he oh he doesn't need the hookshot
anymore right
no I don't think so
cuz then he can take his game nope that
was not my intention
okay nice we got a nice animation out of
it I have two slots open now so I could
take any more of these items but I don't
know if that's what we want green RV get
out of my way you probably take that
green herb do you think we need it
yeah I don't think your gosh I don't
think you're coming back here no way
so take OHS ribbon case well I don't
have room we's full no no we're good
I thought we were full it was because we
were holding all these items what else
should she take this gasp I mean if you
can fit it you might as well she came
here she can visit and then [ __ ] this
turn yeah it's gotten a better view few
times can't fix you someone sent me a
cat photo more specifically my
girlfriend sent me a photo of our cat
and I can't help them look at it I mean
you're only human
and he's only a [ __ ] he's a cat can
you see it
you [ __ ] just chilling Oh dizzy I'm
not even mad yeah so handsome
Oh
thank God you what is going on oh that's
a cow that's a gorilla what is he doing
Oh what do I do
I don't know he seems dead
who reaches get those molotovs out ooh
good thing I had these yeah what I
jumped this these things are creepy yeah
[ __ ] you this is [ __ ] does she not
have run think its legs are jelly she's
she's gonna [ __ ] die if this keeps
happening consider healing you should
heal right right oh my god oh my god my
coat consider healing as my polite way
of saying [ __ ] heal the [ __ ] up
is he dead was that noise oh he died
yeah he's dead
something just happened up in the that
room though
I can't be him okay something happened
up in the control room are you sure yeah
I think he just singed like he like well
you can't go anywhere else anyways
anyways well I can go in the thingy I
don't think you wanna go in the cable
car without Billy though maybe you do I
feel like you do like I'll go up here
that's where you're supposed to go okay
yeah I think stompy stompy
well get in Memphis with your baby must
be stand good all right so I got a
single throw up no I put that back in
well like I just played oh if you popped
out it popped out no wonder this thing
keeps breaking down the power supply
keeps popping out
so is Billy alive you got the hook shop
probably I do
I would imagine I don't think you want
to leave I don't have room for it I had
to get rid of my geese you don't I don't
know like white are they gonna just
transport it I don't know could I get in
and then leave like how about how about
I leave it and I take the hookshot and I
try to drop it when I get it might be
something I could just worth searching
I've already done it [ __ ] that's a total
alive zombie anymore I already did this
guy's super alive I know you're alive oh
he's got a handgun Oh
Magnum you should make room for that
okay sorry am i getting rid of this then
yeah whoops I dropped my magnum handgun
for my monster dog why would you shoot
your penis I don't know oh whoops I
dropped my monster handgun for my Magnum
dog pew pew on Goga blue vien our
collector jaundice or I haven't watched
any of the episodes this season if it's
always sunny really I thought that was
like your favorite show ever used to be
I just fell off it why Seinfeld my
favorite show
actually I don't know I lifestyle oh
speaking of and this is kind of
tangentially related to Knievel and a
dead error I'll pockets have you watched
the haunting of Hill House yet
did I finished it yeah I didn't really
like how it ended the last episode but I
liked the whole thing leading up to that
we I think we talked about it last
episode and I told you I was not
listening because I don't know were you
telling me oh my god
we should replay this back we talked
about it and I said I liked it so far
but you can't like things like this
until you see the end because sometimes
like the like all the questions you did
they don't answer yet it wasn't that
they didn't answer all the questions
it's just that they I just didn't it was
- alright so I read a director
commentary I'm not gonna spoil anything
that I read a director commentary from
Mike Flanagan about a decision they made
for the ending that they cut and I was
like oh [ __ ] that would've been such a
much better ending interesting I almost
wish I hadn't read that but should I
start it I I would have loved the show I
was overall very satisfied it's really
well shot it's um I love it she just
left him it's really well shot it's um
it's got a really fascinating story
writing is really good the way I can eat
it like so easily jumps back and forth
between timelines and between all these
different things going on but I
personally think that the house where
the kids were there
I found that much more interesting than
the present them I was the opposite
because their family reminds me of a my
well you mean you have siblings - but I
have exactly the same I have four
siblings yeah and yeah we have where our
house was haunted so I'd like the family
the way that that episode six with the
four long takes was unreal the way all
the family like [ __ ] comes out when
they're all drinking and stuff that's
happened to my family I haven't seen
them for years they're dead now no just
kidding they're all alive
alright cool herbes oh I don't have room
but I could get rid of so Magnum gun
takes Magnum bullets yes you've solved
it sorry that mean yes you knew the
answer to that you didn't need to ask me
hated I did and you are an ass sorry you
are not a nice person no I'm sorry okay
I'm sorry you answered your own question
and the questions I just wanted it like
confirmation I'm not gonna take both of
these right now I'm just gonna take one
and leave the other one one of those
traffic cones doing there do you think
what's their endgame okay so I can take
a left no I can't because that's a I'll
walk to door knock door I will take
these stairs I'm funny if a door was
locked from this side they're like you
want to unlock it
Claudine that happens when you're on the
other side okay I was like oh I guess
there's nothing up here so you know I
just I guess scream want this uh yeah
you can open it I'll drink it well yeah
if you haven't watched hunting Hillhouse
check it out it's not like I didn't find
it crazy scary there was a I know you
know which one I'm talking about there
was a jump scare that [ __ ] was it in
rawr don't yeah yeah yeah there I mean
there are a lot of scenes in cars but
yes it was and it [ __ ] pooped me into
20 times I mean to do that I got shot
back into mm 18 or 17 free what year it
is I think some of the jump scares were
cheap did you see um there was a there
was a thing that showed all the secret
stuff kidding I saw a few like in the
wallpaper and [ __ ] and like in the
background when it was out of focus but
I got to go back and watch the show is
really good it's one of my favorite like
Netflix things ever
I got like ever now Netflix specifically
right yeah like looks it's like its own
breed where it's like if something good
happens on there everyone's like oh my
god that's really good for Netflix but
no it's it's good in its own right for
sure like the writing Mike Flanagan
knows his stuff and it's encouraging cuz
he's well he did hush he did Gerald game
but he's also doing dr. sleep The
Shining sequel way I saw Gerald's game
that was another one
a giant human being suspended and buy
organic fluids Oh Oh or so I would
surmise um you know spooked Ober you
just like watch a lot of this stuff cuz
you can and you just burn through it so
I watched I've been watching so many
spoopy movies recently
what's poopy it's just a new word for
spooky me okay so when you first set it
I think actually now that I think about
it you set it on can evil the last time
and I assumed it meant like corny spooky
like spoofy I think it can be used that
way but you can also be like I can't
kill this thing I can't kill this Magnum
I don't like using it you have to I got
so spooked who has those other magnum
rounds there were other magnum rounds
back oh did we can we get those still
that was worth it it only took two I
wonder if we can ride the cable car back
I hear it
there's a [ __ ] another one hear it
yeah oh [ __ ] now that's a good camera
angle one yeah so I got him right this
donghae you shot his Magnum dong I
wonder if we can go back in the cable
car said that like six times but there
cuz there are six magnum rounds back in
that uh that we left back there oh I was
not ready for those guys that scared me
don't I know it
oh that was just like that car I'd seen
mm-hmm like Mary stop the shows awesome
definitely worth seeing if you like
scary movies
yeah and shows like I would agree with
you it's been a while since I've seen a
series that is like scary besides I
think American Horror Story season 1 got
me pretty good did you ever watch
American part of season 1 season one was
pretty spoop what was the forest was
season 1 the haunted house
yeah then this there was a circus the
newt then there was an asylum I think
that was third fourth season the current
one is a like a nuclear fallout shelter
I am NOT I fell off not because it's not
good I just fell off I love anthology
shows so I can't watch that much scary
stuff all the time because it does keep
me up at night if I get over spooked
I've been watching like four or five
oh I'm I think I [ __ ] up yeah it's all
right four or five scary movies a week
yeah I've been watching a lot this week
I watched I've never seen Paranormal
Activity that [ __ ] with me I never saw
it so I saw it yesterday that's scary I
don't know if it might find time really
the later ones there are some creepy
ones of paranor likes is they made like
eight now right so the first three are
pretty the first two are really I
actually really liked three the three
goes back it's a prequel it it's
what's-her-name the Katie as a kid Katie
and her sister no way somehow I like it
scary as [ __ ] like it's when what do
they call the monster Toby oh I don't
know I think it has a name no well it's
name is Toby and they oh really so yeah
I found and maybe this is just me but oh
[ __ ] I've so many bullets I found that
when I watched nothing krebons - I think
I have ink ribbons so I can no I can't I
can't pick those up you drop something
what's that Keith - I don't know you
inspect it Oh factory I found that when
I watched it again so this is something
me watching a movie that came out in
2007 and I watched it yeah I watched it
last night for the first time I was like
this is all a result of that stupid
boyfriend
like that guy subtle Myka he was
constantly like what did they say they
said don't antagonize it they said don't
communicate with it like don't use a
Ouija board and they were like just
leave it alone just leave him be
and it just goes away and guess what he
was like if
[ __ ] video he was like oh this like
little [ __ ] like what does he think
he's gonna do like walk into this powder
that I'm putting in front of the door
let's see what you do you little [ __ ]
and then it does and then he's like this
is my house not gonna have somebody like
screwing up my house and gets a Ouija
board and he's like let's see you like
talk [ __ ] to me now you little [ __ ] and
then it [ __ ] lights it on fire and
threatens them and he's like yeah and
then later on like the photo of them is
broken and they scratch his face
specifically and he's like oh you're
gonna scratch my face little [ __ ] and
it's just like that guy's going to kill
you and you are stupid you are such a
stupid like one of those like really
stupid like alpha [ __ ] male things
eat he literally says there's a line of
that film where he goes you lose my
house you're my girlfriend and I'm gonna
solve this and it's like you didn't even
believe in this [ __ ] like two days ago
why don't you just [ __ ] get an
exorcist you [ __ ] sorry - is Katie
sisters family and then three is both
yeah so - is her sister who's like I
don't should I save I'd say we got like
15 more minutes in the episode if you
want to wait you don't do anything rash
hey it's a keyhole
good cuz I was about to use my Malta
keyhole you never know it's at a
railroad track you going back on a train
I don't know yes can't twist it twist it
good now the turntable should move but
how do I turn aids I hope you can go
back as the grenade launchers now you
can go back they wouldn't have done that
you don't have enough spaces yeah I
don't have a grenade launcher dude if I
can't go back we're really screwed
well hey no you're not you have the
Magnum which we did in the last time but
you can go back so let me ask you this I
can now turn the table pick this up you
idiot guys don't really know and I want
to pick up these [ __ ] I want to pick
up the ink ribbon thank you I'm gonna
take this and I'm gonna drop it on the
floor cuz it's easier to pick something
up on the floor that is on that damn
counter stupid alright so getting some
progress done what else have I seen
recently I saw I've been seeing so many
scary movies I want to see the new
Halloween apparently it's pretty
apparently it's really good Patrick
Lepik was tweeting about it and he's
saying it's super nice I saw I I've seen
the devil or is it
oh the Devil Wears Prada no this is a
very different film it's a Korean horror
I love Kay horror here live okay drama
but not a lot about Kay horror that
shit's [ __ ] up and it's really good
every time the ones I've seen I should
make a list of like Kay horror where I
was like damn
[ __ ] is good I'm trying to think of what
I have come in contact with Korean
horror I don't know if I was supposed to
do this like I don't know what I'm doing
not getting a lot of I don't know
supervision here like do I want to do
this I don't know no honestly I don't
where'd you go what floor I don't know I
said dick what I said take me down no I
don't what floor you got oh
I haven't looked at my map in like ten
years
[ __ ] if there are these lizard things
down here I don't have a lot of Magnum
bully's left oh wait don't
yeah I don't think you wanna go through
far ahead oh god what am i doing
there's a there's an item over here
magnum rounds I hope I don't know let me
go over there yeah yeah go there just
don't go through the next door yet this
whole area is super scary
you can't save around here can you back
up there there's a door here no open
your map after you pick those things up
I hope those are magnum rounds oh my god
are you okay Rebecca where is everybody
they should have arrived here before me
haven't you seen them that's unfortunate
if we go straight from here we should
arrive at an old mansion oh man that
guy's dead come on let's go probably no
point worrying about them you won't make
it come on let's go Rebecca all right
just be careful I never saw him again
what this is very very dramatic do not
use this key yet you're about to pick up
a key don't use it check out this room
though yeah I can do that what it's no
need on that hallway
you heard the game there's no need and
you go back up you heard me
oh wait no that's don't what that's the
one I don't think you want to open I am
afraid to do anything right now try
bringing the turn the elevator thing
back up once I remember how to do that
I'm gonna totally do that it's to the
other side yeah around here it's not
good you saved it before you came down
which is good I just might have a tough
I did not you you I mean in general you
did alright well this is gonna be funny
I don't get five nine in a row you have
a lot of ammo just be ready - oh my god
heal with one green herb oh you're mad
I'm what yes
yeah it's the other one in the other
side I Chi why why I don't want to die
oh wait it's in the middle isn't it no
yeah it's near that rubble pile um hey
that's it press the switch specifically
yeah oh come on
yeah get ready to move and shoot
mm [ __ ] [ __ ] oh no oh no no God what is
that it's got a really big middle finger
a prototype time oh yeah so dodge it and
then Magnum it and then totally do not
shoot it when it's recoiling because
it's invincible
what's a recoil like when you shoot him
any recoils or when he when you shoot
him and he's like she's mumbling shoot
his butt but Duke oh my god do I have to
shoot I have to shoot bite him in this
tiny square yeah so when he's to get him
you might want to heal I mean I don't
you have much to lose by healing it's
not gonna make a difference you might as
well yeah like I move in heel or heel
and move either way I move you got one
more Magnum balloon I'm just a [ __ ]
nut ton of manic oh [ __ ] up oh yeah
sure
oh I don't know if those work wow you
just got so lucky
yeah handgun just I mean you have no huh
thank god this is the improved handgun
yeah if you dodge you're fine he's not
too hard to dodge I guess just do it
correctly oh my god he's dumb yeah
you're fine
wait horn stop okay god I have all these
[ __ ] maybe you can't keep shooting
I'm sorry oh you got him nevermind okay
sweet yay
no one's infinitely better than I
thought I would no offense to you it
just was not a good situation
I'm fine with this result okay elevator
let's get the [ __ ] out of here first try
with a handgun no less well I think if
you hadn't wasted that fifth Magnum
round I'm gonna kill him well you didn't
waste I uh II don't know I just I know
what's recommended that all right
you did good it why don't I feel like
you took away from it just then though
it's kind of like when you say I'm sorry
but you did really well
no but thank you Oh am I not going
anywhere I've done this in a real
elevator before KITT you've done what
you know you're getting an elevator and
walk into the wall you get no later it's
like not going any when you're like whew
okay so for is to progress in this story
I don't think you want to do that yeah
where's Billy I don't know I think he's
dead so you wanna go to one maybe wall
is lose like a bad guy in there I'm
gonna die I'd say level one yeah that
brings you back to like the original
area so you can get the Magnum round you
can get
open open open open open those two
molotovs also probably really helped do
you think cuz I didn't think they hit
him no I did it's just they don't he
doesn't light on fire like the leeches
do whoa yeah this is the train crash
from way earlier on so I think there are
ribbons in the main hall you can just
save and then mm-hmm sorry oh there's a
knife what's that noise you're not gonna
use anything you should be in the main
hall now in here oh yeah that you'll
climb up the ladder soon you got a
couple more hallways to go through it
over I hope there's a ribbon here well
actually I have ribs we good yaks you
could say that I'm that was a while back
toward the end the game no monkeys no
monkeys monkeys about hey that's great
well
abbis maybe next episode who maybe to a
typewriter yeah
look you'll bet the grenade launcher
back you'll get everything so now you
have access to the whole game aside from
wherever you're going which is good
because I think this is the point where
you really want to like oh I don't have
in [ __ ] ink ribbon there are in the
room right and up stair to think I don't
know open your map
there's your magnum rounds - you might
as well pick those I think they're the
red things aren't there no curse warned
you left them next to a typewriter wait
what if I took them with me
this is really bad no you can just go
back to yeah see that was just the floor
Iran oh wait no go to the left my butt
yeah that one's close okay so okay you
got the shotgun shells in the morgue
earlier right yes we got the shotgun
shells in the morgue oh wait are you
going the right way I thought it was oh
yeah you are sorry
remember the dumb this puzzle was well
it was a matter of perspective I do
remember feeling a little random pick up
I hope bless you and grab bless you
actually that we've been like such a
pain to like not have it with me that's
like go back and get some more Oh nope I
think you're in good shape I think we're
doing very good sweet probably need to
make more molotovs next episode in
general but you got more Magnum has gas
but we need the one I got the gas but I
don't got the one don't I know that game
okay sweet well I'm in there yeah well
we'll be back next week thanks for
joining us as always everybody go wait
it's gonna be almost Halloween in a few
days
27th I guess next this webinar always
Wednesday because I'm in a I'm like
going out on Halloween the actual day
because I missed the weekend cuz it's
twitchcon well if Halloween's Wednesday
maybe we'll try to do something if we
obviously this is the episode before
Halloween maybe we'll do something for
after Halloween
that sounds good also I know people are
asking if we're gonna play Revelations
for extra life I'm gonna talk to
gentleman who's planning our stuff I
don't know we'll figure it out let's do
it
yeah in the meantime we'll keep
everybody updated I'll go in discord
more because I there's not a lot of
people talking in there I will join it
cool well thank you everybody
as always we'll see you later ignore the
different outro this is just a different
studio you've been watching GameSpot
daily Saturday's duck caller